barron coming out he's three and four
with a 372 earned run average this is
only his third start at home
that a boy this is a two for one ball
nicely
done brandon woodruff yeah imagine a lot
more relaxed after the birth of his
daughter
earlier this week
big pitch here here's the three two a
two down
this one shot in right field and ryan
braun's got it six teams total between
these two divisions and they're
scheduled would qualify among the 16
teams that's pretty impressive yeah good
divisions and brewers in that mix
there's a good pitch wow down and in
slider
first strikeout for brandon woodruff
that was strikeouts coming to fastball
not this time
and good pitch
[Applause]
there's another strikeout for woodrip
that's the second consecutive batter
that's gone down via strikeout brings up
daniel vogelbach just got to the brewers
yesterday playing in his second game as
the dh
this one ripped into right field base
hit down the line and that's going to
give milwaukee
the lead in this game as vogelbach
slides into second just beats the throw
that's his third hit
in two games as a milwaukee brewer he
really did buggy whip that fastball up
and in
yeah after the curveball for a strike
that tried to come up on him
[Applause]
and he just turns on it line drives down
the line in right able to get into
second base brewers on the board first
well the first time through the lineup
they were one for seven
and that was hernandez who got the base
hit the lead off the game
and there's a base hit for hernandez
that's in the gap look out mercano's off
to the races he's going to come all the
way around and score from first base and
we are tied at one as cesar hernandez
has his 14th double of the year
[Applause]
big hit another
big double for hernandez once that hit
the gap there was no thought
mercado going to score easily from first
base by the time gamma could get it in
here you go finally a broken through
against woodruff and let's see now
runner and scoring position in hernandez
as jose ramirez steps in
fastball swung on driven high and deep
to right this has a chance way back
there home run jose ramirez
oh it just made it
and ramirez has put the indians in front
by a score of three to one
braun got back there made a leap at the
wall but he couldn't get to it
maybe
a row into the seats in right
but he got it over the wall and jose
ramirez with home run number nine on the
season and we go to the brewer half of
inning number six as casting hero makes
his way to the plate he will lead off
this one hit to right all the way back
and gone for casting hira that shot
right out of here for a lead off home
run
and the 11th on the season for hira and
milwaukee within three to two how about
that power on a breaking pitch
straight away right field you know most
of his home runs have been kind of
gapped again and with two down it's
going to be
daniel vogelback coming up
against nick wikrand
the one-two
got him looking fastball painted
perfectly by nick witkin
top of the eighth inning orlando arcia
leads off for milwaukee 3-1 pitch to
arcia
swinging a high fly deep left field this
ball is tattooed and gone
we're tied 3-3
orlando arcia home run number three on
the season
deadlocks it back up to a 3-3 score
he was sitting dead red on that 3-1
fastball and he made up for it big time
josh hader on pitch for milwaukee
in a dozen games has not given up the
hit
smashed left field yelling's back on the
run won't get it top the wall plays it
well here's the throw and mercado slides
in safely with a lead-off double
they're going with five infielders this
is where you just have to just
trust yourself stay short and quick and
put it in play somewhere
there is game winner bingo cesar
hernandez singles mercado scores and the
indians have their walk-off win
but i'll tell you what they had the
right man up at the right spot because
he makes adjustments he finds a way to
use the whole field
shortens the swing
put it in play and the first two guys
they get back-to-back hits
you know
to win the ball game that's
just perfect hernandez who has been one
of the indians best hitter
hitters this year with runners in
scoring position too came into the night
batting 400 with runners in scoring
position he drives home mercado to win
it